Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This is an episode that doesn't have the usual
visual fireworks and is expected to get fewer
clicks, but it is an important story to tell,
and because of your support, we are able to
cover a paper like this.
So now, get this, this is a non-invasive brain-to-brain
interface that uses EEG to record brain signals
and TMS to deliver information to the brain.
The non-invasive part is quite important,
it basically means that we don't need to drill
a hole in the head of the patients.
That's a good idea.
This image shows three humans connected via
computers, 2 senders and one receiver.
The senders provide information to the receiver
about something he would otherwise not know
about, and we measure if they are able to
collaboratively solve a problem together.
These people never met each other, and don't
even know each other, and they can collaborate
through this technique directly via brain
signals.
Wow!
The BCI means brain-computer interface, and
the CBI, as you guessed, the computer-brain
interface.
So these brain signals can be encoded and
decoded and freely transferred between people
and computers.
Insanity.
After gathering all this information, the
receiver makes a decision, which the senders
also have access to, and can transmit some
more information if necessary.
So what do they use it for?
Of course, to play Tetris!
Jokes aside, this is a great experiment where
the goal is to clear a line.
Simple enough, right?
Not so much, because there is a twist.
The receiver only sees what you see here on
the left side.
This is the current piece we have to place
on the field, but the receiver has no idea
how to rotate it because he doesn't see its
surroundings.
But the senders do, so they transmit the appropriate
information to the receiver who will now be
able to make an informed decision as to how
to rotate the piece correctly to clear a line.
So, does it work?
The experiment is designed in a way that there
is a 50% chance to be right without any additional
information for the receiver, so this will
be the baseline result.
And the results are between 75% and 85%, which
means that the interface is working, and the
brain-to-brain collaboration is now a reality.
I am out of words.
The paper also talks about brain-to-brain
social networks, and all kinds of science
fiction like that.
My head is about to explode with the possibilities,
who knows, maybe in a few years, we can make
a superintelligent brain that combines all
of our expertise and does research for all
of us.
Or, writes Two Minute Papers episodes.
This paper is a must read.
Do you have any other ideas as to how this
could enhance our lives?
Let me know below in the comments.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!